[Applause]
all right and we have someone very
special who requested that song in
particular he is the host of adam eats
the 80s give it up for adam richmond
[Music]
what's up adam
what's up kelly oh my gosh i brought you
my country western glamour glitz and
glamorous do you see my shoulder pads
dude
i look so big i look so good with my
shoulder pads um we're gonna
we're gonna talk about your [ __ ]
thank you we're going to talk about your
show in a second but first why do you
love that song
um my dad this is actually a picture of
him right here um my dad may rest in
peace was a big country fan my first
concert was the statler brothers oh wow
and um i grew up hearing him play
ronnie millsap songs i think people
nowadays don't realize how popular he
was but you know from like 74 to 78 he
had something like seven number one hits
and so i've always loved his music i've
always loved uh
loved him and it's just really special
to hear you sing it i love that he could
have named that smoky mountain rain too
i'm just saying there's another song
there but tell us about your new show
it's about food in the 80s right correct
so adam eats the 80s is looking back at
this incredibly dynamic and energetic
and incredible
decade through the prism of food and
looking at your audience they already
know the fashion was amazing the fads
the big hair the big shoulder pads but
people don't realize that it changed
american food forever there were brands
that emerged that became national and
global icons and it also
like between the invention of the
microwave between fast food and
drive-through is proliferating between
reagan saying you could advertise
directly to kids and sugar cereals with
video games
so wait i have a question that wait do
you have like a favorite 80s candy
yes there are so many candies uh i love
but i think that you know in 84 um
nerds was actually voted candy of the
year
and
people don't realize how fascinating the
story behind nerds was this was the
company that had licensed the willy
wonka brand and one scientist saw the
little bits of everlasting gobstopper in
the bottom of the machine and he said
let's let's coat these little hardened
bits of sweetened uh sugar with you know
acetic acid make them sour make them
fruity and the everlasting gobstopper
became the nerd and those little designs
on the package i think i sent you guys
some
um those little designs the graphic
designer used to doodle them on his desk
and they just decided hey let's just
make he's the logo
this is brand new information
i did not know that that's what nerds
was
i loved one of the scientists
they're so good one of the scientists
kids actually named them so
you can't blame it
[Applause]
all right well wait we have a clip of
adam eats the 80s take a look this is
what i do for you
the 1980s was a deliciously doughy
decade you were either making dough
baking dough or eating it whether it was
auntie ann's decision to expand into
malls and stick with their recipe for
all of these years or dominoes
attempting to cut a slice of the
breakfast market with a pizza gone too
soon
the echoes of the 80s can still be heard
today
and some of them
are really really tasty
thank you so much adam i love you
come back on my show
[Music]